well after a year of spending a lot of  time indoors as seen there in that piece  more people are enjoying  outdoor space at home that's why a local  nursery is offering  to help spruce things up a lot of people  are a little bit tired of  you know staying inside and doing that  whole thing so this is a good place to  come out  get some fresh air see some beautiful  plants  and kind of change your environment at  home as well moon valley nurseries has  three locations around the valley they  encourage folks to visit them  if they want to do something different  in their yard their advice for everyone  be sure to adjust your watering  schedules as the seasons change  don't overlook the fertilizer which is  so necessary here in the desert